- There's one nurse
that I work with
who is seven months pregnant,
and this nurse actually
wants the vaccine.
She said, "I want the vaccine.
I'll get the vaccine.
Just wait until I have my baby
and I will come
back vaccinated."
And she was forced to
resign because they said no.
At seven months pregnant,
this is someone who
actually wanted it,
and they're holding
the line and said,
"No, you're not gonna be
here come September 27th."
And she resigned in
lieu of being fired
so she can keep some benefits
there, but she was forced out.
(gentle music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and we're doing something
a little different today.
You know, I've been
telling you guys
that my inbox is
absolutely blowing up
from people reaching out to
me about losing their jobs
or potentially losing their jobs
because of these
vaccine mandates.
I'm hearing from people
in the healthcare field,
I'm hearing from
airline workers,
people just across the
economy, across the country.
And I wanted to
start interviewing a
couple of the people
that are speaking
out against this.
And I saw a tweet from this guy
that I'm about to
introduce to you.
He is a frontline ER
nurse, former EMT,
and current
congressional candidate
in New York's 3rd
District, Kevin Surdi.
Welcome to "The Rubin Report."
- Thank you so
much for having me.
It's an honor to be here.
- Kevin, I mentioned to you
right before we started,
New York's 3rd district,
I'm homegrown Syosset, man.
That means my parents are in
what could potentially
be your district.
What do you want people
to know about you
and why you're running,
before we get to the specifics
on vaccines and all that?
- Yeah, so I'm running to
really bring back representation
to the district.
And as a congressman, your
title is representative,
and I feel they have
completely lost sight of that.
And a lot of them
are running for
to keep themselves in office
and they run for the title and
the position of congressman.
And they've
completely lost sight
of what their job really is,
and that's to represent the
people that voted them in.
I'm running on a term
limits platform as well,
which will limit that
availability to turn
it into a career,
'cause I see Congress as
a service to your country.
It's not a career to
get yourself rich.
- Okay, so I just mentioned
my inbox is just crazy
with people reaching out to me,
wanting their
stories to be heard,
just telling me about all
sorts of awful things,
having to make the choice
between basically being fired
or going against their
conscience related
to the vaccines.
But I saw a tweet from you.
This is why I reached
out to you specifically.
You sent this just a
couple of days ago.
"I'm an ER nurse on Long Island.
I'm pro-vaccine
and anti-mandate.
In my department, 4
nurses either resigned
or will be fired
due to the mandates.
24 administrators
have been fired.
Another 5 were forced against
their will to get the shot.
This mandate will
destroy hospitals."
Okay, so that's what's
happening to you in Long Island.
Obviously, this is
close to my heart.
Well, first, do you mind
if I ask what hospital?
- I work for Northwell,
one of the larger hospital
systems on Long Island.
- Gotcha.
Now that in mind, we also
have the governor of New York,
who nobody voted for,
who in essence is firing
83,000 healthcare workers.
The people we were
told are the heroes,
they are going to be replaced
by the National Guard
if they so choose not
to get the vaccine.
So, I'll let you
unpack that tweet.
But to start, you're
saying you're pro-vaccine,
you're anti-mandate.
So, do you wanna clean
that up a little bit?
- Absolutely, and I,
myself, I'm vaccinated.
I got both my shots and
my family got their shots.
All my friends got it.
I think the vaccine does help
limit the symptoms of
COVID if you get it.
So, it does prevent ICU stays.
It does work.
The problem is it
doesn't prevent you
from spreading the virus.
So the vaccine that
I got, it is a risk,
or any vaccine we take, any
medicine, any medical procedure,
there's always risks to it,
and understanding those
risks, I got the vaccine.
And I would encourage you
people to get the vaccine.
However, it's not a
perfect vaccine yet.
This thing cannot
stop transmission.
It can't stop you
from getting COVID,
which the CDC also just
said the other day.
We can't be firing people
that choose not to
get the vaccine.
Thankfully, my wife was
pregnant during this
and we chose not to
get her the vaccine
while she was pregnant.
After she gave birth,
we gave her the vaccine.
But what if my wife was a nurse?
My wife would be forced to
be either get the vaccine
while you're pregnant or fired.
And thankfully at the time,
we had the opportunity
of that choice.
And that choice is not
being offered today.
So I'm pro-vaccine,
I just don't think
anybody should be fired
if they think they don't want
the vaccine at this time.
- You know, bizarrely
on the pregnancy front,
you may have seen the
head of the CDC, Walensky,
just a couple of
days ago saying,
"Oh, it's completely
fine for pregnant women
and for breastfeeding
women," et cetera, et cetera,
except there's simply no way
they could have that data yet.
- It's too soon.
If we look at following the
science, we're all scientists.
We have degrees.
We've been doing this
for over 20 years.
Data takes time.
This has only been
six, eight months.
Some of these women that
have had the vaccine
and given birth,
it's not long enough
for us to see the effects
of what's happening.
And there have been so
many FDA approved drugs
and treatments in the past
that we're realizing
now are not safe
and they have recalls.
And it's just too
soon to be mandated.
It's gotta be a
choice at this point.
- When you mentioned some of
the nurses and administrators
that you know that now are
either being forced to step down
or ultimately will be fired,
or in essence,
they're furloughed.
You don't have to go to
work, but you don't get paid,
so you're fired by any
reasonable estimation.
What have their
rationalities been
as to why they're not
getting vaccinated?
- It ranges.
There's one nurse
that I work with
who is seven months pregnant,
and this nurse actually
wants the vaccine.
She said, "I want the vaccine.
I'll get the vaccine.
Just wait until I have my baby
and I will come
back vaccinated."
And she was forced to
resign because they said no.
At seven months pregnant,
this is someone who
actually wanted it
and they're holding
the line and said,
"No, you're not gonna be
here come September 27th."
And she resigned in
lieu of being fired
so she can keep some benefits
there, but she was forced out.
I have another great colleague
of mine who's in her 30s.
She's had a stroke already.
She's blind in one eye,
had open heart surgery,
and we know that there
is a very small risk,
but the risk is there, of
blood clots with the vaccine.
And she said, "I'm
not taking that risk.
I'm already blind in one eye.
I don't wanna be blind in
another eye if I get this clot
and I'm predispositioned
to have a stroke."
This is somebody who is a nurse.
She knows what she's talking
about, and she was fired.
We have others on
religious beliefs
and others who just don't know.
They've had COVID, they
have the antibodies,
and the whole purpose
to get the vaccine
is to give you antibodies.
So we're a little confused.
If you already have
natural antibodies,
why are you giving me another
shot to have antibodies
and then requiring me to
get multiple boosters?
- Have you brought that,
sorry to interrupt,
have you guys brought that
up with administrators?
I mean, I get that it's
just going down the chain
and everyone's just like,
"Well, they told me to do it
and you told me to do it
and we're gonna do it."
But when you bring that up about
the natural antibody thing,
which nobody seems
to wanna discuss,
Fauci and the head of the
CDC and everything else,
what are the administrators
saying to you guys?
- The administrators are saying
they're following
the CDC protocol,
and they're not going back
to us with the science
that we know that they have.
A lot of these administrators
are doctors and nurses,
and this isn't a nursing thing.
This has spread out
to pharmacists and
doctors and nurses.
It's all throughout healthcare
of multiple people wanting
the vaccine or not wanting it.
And the majority of them
have already had COVID.
They've tested positive
through blood work
that they have antibodies,
and they're being told,
"No, you still have
to get the shot."
And that's what
we're really fighting
and I'm trying to represent
a whole group here,
because it doesn't make sense.
If we're giving you a shot
to give you antibodies,
but you already have antibodies,
which has also been
proven to be more likely
at stopping you from
getting the virus
if you have natural antibodies
than the synthetic
ones from the vaccine.
- When you hear the,
quote-unquote, "trusted class"
and the media people
talk about COVID
yet not bring up
natural antibodies,
not bring up some of the
other remedies for COVID,
we're not allowed to talk
about some of this stuff,
it's like, what are
you guys thinking?
Are you shocked that
suddenly medicine
is not allowed to
be talked about,
that certain remedies are not
allowed to be talked about?
- Well, I think
governance should employ.
They should not be dictating
how medicine should work.
We are the people, we've
gone to medical school,
we've gone to nursing school,
we've gone to pharmacy school.
We know what we're
talking about.
We know how to treat this.
They should not be telling
us what we should be doing,
what we can't be doing.
And it's not based on science.
We're not seeing that
there's any data behind this,
so we can only allude
that this is some
kind of a power grab
or there's money behind it.
There's some other reason
because it's not the science.
We're trying to follow
the science of it
and they're telling us not to.
- If I would have
said to you a year ago
at the height of
COVID, let's say,
or even a little more than a
year ago, year and a half ago,
it's now May of 2020,
something like that,
if I would have said to you,
"In a year and a half from now,
half of your friends
and colleagues
are gonna be stepping down
or forced out or fired
because they didn't
take a vaccine,"
what do you think
you would have said,
when at that time you guys
were the greatest
heroes of all time?
- I probably would have laughed
and I'd say, "There's no way
that's possible to happen."
When we were in this,
the thick of it,
we didn't have
enough PPE to wear.
I myself was wearing the
same mask for weeks on ends.
And before COVID, that mask
was supposed to be worn
one patient at a time.
You wear it, you take it off,
you throw in the garbage,
you get a new one.
And we were wearing this
for weeks at the same time.
I even had one of those
straps break on a mask
and I was told, "Just
tie it together."
So we went through
a lot, sacrifice,
and it's a risk that we
all knew we were taking.
We were in healthcare,
that's what we do.
We're first responders,
and any of us would do
it again immediately
without any hesitation.
And we're still doing it.
We're still treating
COVID patients,
many vaccinated COVID
patients as well.
And for them to say,
"You're gonna be fired
for not getting a vaccine,"
after everything we just went
through, it's mind boggling.
And where I'm really sticking
on why this doesn't make sense,
because we are in a
healthcare pandemic,
we are in a national
nursing shortage
right now, currently today,
before a lot of people are
even being fired or terminated.
I get text messages
every single day,
all across Long Island,
begging for overtime,
"Come in, we need help.
$250 extra to come in."
If you lose just one
or two providers,
you are gonna devastate
that department.
We're already short-staffed.
So if you're gonna
fire more people,
I don't understand
how that's better,
because me personally, I'd
much rather get treated
by an unvaccinated
person with antibodies
than being treated
by nobody at all.
And there's gonna be a time
where you're gonna
come to that hospital
and your care is
gonna be delayed
because there are not
gonna be enough people
to care for you.
- Right, and by the way,
do we even have any numbers
or do you know of
any numbers of,
at the peak of this thing,
unvaccinated healthcare workers
that were somehow infecting
people at hospitals?
Have they done any studies
on that that you know of?
- Not to my knowledge
and I highly doubt it.
And a lot of us got COVID
during the peak of it.
You're out for two or three
weeks and you're fine.
You're right back.
Yes, it was devastating.
A lot of people did die.
I held the hands
of dying patients.
It was a lot to deal
with in the hospitals.
But there's a high
survivability rate.
Personally, in one of
the hospital systems,
we did lose a few
healthcare workers,
but the majority
of them were fine.
And if they got COVID,
they got the antibodies
and they're still
working currently today.
Why are we forcing
this vaccine on them?
Even though we think
the vaccine does work
and it limits your symptoms,
but a lot of people have
very legitimate reasons
like I spoke about to
not get the vaccine.
Why are we firing these people?
It just doesn't make sense.
We need healthcare professionals
right now more than ever,
and if we're short-staffed,
it doesn't make sense.
- For some of my audience
that may be hesitant,
and as I have said completely
from the beginning
the entire time,
it's that I believe the
same position you're taking,
which is that you have
to make the right choice
for yourself and you should
consult with your doctor
and your age and your
health and your diet
and all of those
things should matter.
If someone's hesitant,
do you have a recommendation
on which one they should take?
Or just anything on
that side of things?
- It'd be more of a conversation
between them and their doctor.
There hasn't really
been too much
to prove one's better
than the other.
Personally, I had Moderna,
the two shots that I got,
my family got that one,
and we got that one
because that's what
they offered that day.
If they were offering Pfizer,
I would have gotten
the Pfizer one.
So, that's all up to
interpersonal choice.
- What of your colleagues
that are now stepping down
or being furloughed, et cetera,
do they know what they're
gonna do with their lives?
Most people don't
have months in salary
just waiting in the bank,
and you didn't think you were
gonna step away from a career,
and here we are.
- It's very stressful.
A lot of them have kids, too.
There's one nurse,
she's a single mom,
been a nurse for quite
a few years in the ER,
and she very reluctantly got
the vaccine against her will.
She did not want this at all.
She's very distressed
because she's already
gotten the first shot.
She goes, "I can't lose my job.
I'm a single mom.
If I lose my job, I can't afford
my house or to feed my kid.
I don't have a choice here."
And that's just horrible to do
to someone who's just sacrificed
their whole last year,
working overtime,
coming in extra.
We used to get undressed
outside of our house.
I personally
quarantined two weeks
away from my family
in the beginning,
'cause I didn't know if
I would bring this home.
And now this is someone that
wants to care for her child
and she doesn't
have another option.
So, she was forced
to get that vaccine.
- Is there anything else
you want people to know?
We're gonna do a whole
series of these shows.
I'm gonna try to talk to people
in all sorts of
different industries.
And I just think it's important
that people realize
what's actually
happening on the ground.
Is there anything
that we missed here
that you wanna get out?
- Yeah, just two.
If you do want to
find more information,
my website,
SurdiForCongress.com,
S-U-R-D-I forCongress.com,
a ton of information on
there you can follow.
And one note about the governors
using the National Guard,
this is a horrible
policy decision.
God bless the people that
are in the National Guard.
They're absolutely heroes.
They do a ton of
great work for us.
But if we're gonna
activate the medical people
from the National Guard,
these are doctors,
nurses, pharmacists,
and they're working
right now in hospitals.
The National Guard is a
part-time military position.
What's gonna happen is when
the Guard is activated,
you're gonna pull these
full-time doctors and nurses
that are working at
other hospitals today
away from their home hospital
and put them in other hospitals.
So we're just gonna make
staffing shorter all around
by deploying the National Guard.
And I don't know if a
lot of people know that.
The National Guard is a
horrible policy decision,
amongst from a lot of
other horrible ones.
It's not gonna
solve the problem.
It's actually gonna
make it a lot worse.
- Are you hopeful that enough
people will hear the message
that you're trying
to get out there,
that enough people will
come around and be like,
"Oh yeah, maybe my own personal
choice is more important
than what the government
demands that I do."
Do you sense that
something's moving there,
that there's momentum there?
- There are a lot of people.
My big hope is the governor
comes to her senses
and rescinds the order.
- Yeah, I don't think so.
- I don't think
so, it's my hope.
Alabama, they rescinded it.
There are some places
that they're not doing it.
They kinda told the state,
"We're not gonna do this."
And we're hoping they
stand their ground
and they continue to
say, "This is my choice.
Either I have antibodies
or I don't have antibodies,
but you can't force
something that is this new."
A lot of people argue that
the vaccine is not new.
The research has been there.
And I fully agree, the
research has been there.
But they haven't
used it on humans.
This is a new thing that's
being actually used.
We're still in a trial phase.
I was fine getting the shot.
I looked at the
research and the data
and I took the acknowledged
risk to get it.
That was my choice.
It was our choice that my
wife didn't get the vaccine
while she was pregnant.
Don't take the
choice out of people,
especially the people that are
fighting on the front lines
to protect their community.
They're putting themselves
and their families at risk.
They still want to work.
They still wanna care for you.
And if you've got the vaccine,
you can still spread the virus.
So why is it that
we're firing people?
Just give them a test.
I'd much rather test
every healthcare employee.
When we come into work,
give us all a test.
And that way we know for sure,
we don't have COVID that day
and we won't spread
it to the patient.
I think every healthcare
worker can get behind that.
The flu vaccine was
mandated and they said,
"Well, if you don't want the
flu vaccine, wear a mask."
There's always been
another option.
That's all we're asking for.
Give us a test, let us know,
we absolutely don't have it,
and that's actually the
safest thing you can do.
But that's not even happening.
This is a power grab.
It feels like a
punishment of some sort,
and it's just not the
right thing to do.
And patients are
going to suffer,
which is why I'm
standing in this line.
I can't have this
affect patient care.
- Kevin, we, the people,
stand with you guys.
It's SurdiForCongress.com.
We're gonna link to
it right down below.
And keep New York 3,
especially Syosset, safe.
That's Billy Joel
country over there.
- Will do.
Please give us your support.
There's a place to
donate on the website.
Unfortunately, politics
does require money
to get the message out.
It's a sad part.
Hopefully when I'm in Congress,
I can try to fix that.
Send a donation, help us
get that message out there.
And please look for your votes.
And if there's
anything you need,
please reach out and contact me.
All my information
is on the website.
I'd love to speak
with you individually.
- Kevin Surdi, thanks so much.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.